hello welcome to honest trailer
commentaries do you hate paper straws I
love the environment but at this point
useless absolutely useless we're talking
about frozen - today
this is honest trailer commentary so
watch frozen to come back here for
uncensored thoughts we're gonna do a
deep dive into the process behind making
the video we're going to respond to some
viewer questions we're gonna show you
some deleted scenes we're gonna tease
next week's honest trailer yeah that
makes me want to take a nice iced coffee
with my mouth if you want frozen - you
talk to two 30-something dudes and but I
feel like we're able to to evaluate
because there's plenty of Disney
children's films we love I loved frozen
I think it's it was so overrated that it
became underrated
I guess maybe yeah it's a in retrospect
one of the all-time great movie
soundtracks are as far as original songs
that I'll agree with you I always I
always thought that frozen was an
average movie with great songs yeah and
I thought this was a pretty good movie
with very average song yeah so it all it
all sort of equals oh yeah I think that
this I didn't finish frozen and think
who I wonder where this goes next yeah
clearly
and I think Disney's admitted as much
that they did not see this coming
they didn't see the the force that it
became and plot wise they unfortunately
told a complete story in the first one
so they had to invent some [ __ ] with
sequels is like you have to we mentioned
it kind of briefly the trailer you have
to like undo all of the stuff that gets
resolved in the first movie in order to
give you a plot for the second movie so
it's like and they lived happily ever
after until Elsa started hearing voices
okay yeah they haven't on adjust be
married is boring so it's like what if
you can't propose yeah they're still
completely in love with each other and
on the same page but what if she became
a [ __ ] about certain words that he uses
high jinks so yeah and then they expand
the world they take you beyond did we
decide it's arendale Irondale it's
arendelle arendelle excuse me and we say
Arundale ah the punks on both their
houses canceled yeah canceled canceled
canceled yeah so we go up to North North
Andhra Soldier which with limited
success I think thank you the enchanted
forest
yeah chanted for ya and that's that's
really all they had it seems like they
were just kind of brainstorming like
throwing stuff up on the wall and then
because animation takes like two to four
years to make they had to just kind of
press play because you got to write the
script then you gotta write the songs
then you gotta animate it and it's got
to come out before kids grow out of
frozen Halloween costumes yeah I feel
like it's the thing like you can't
really the one thing they didn't do they
thought they were gonna do is I thought
they were going to die orphan them yeah
when I found the ship I was like oh my
god like they're it's like so I'm
actually very glad they were not D
orphans because I thought we were
heading down that road right but yeah it
feels like they're just gonna they were
kind of like the keeping pace for a
second sort of wasting time and like
what do you what do you got left like
where did Elsa's powers come from
they're like alright what else can you
do and like
it's magic in the north yeah we can make
that work sure sure sure it's like 90
minutes it's it's it's what risk is for
a modern animated movies pretty brisk
mm-hmm which I appreciate and I
appreciate the pun too so let's watch
our honest no more frozen - electric
Boogaloo and see what else we have to
say
[Music]
from the studio who brought you Lion
King one and a half
Mulan two and lady in the [ __ ] two
scamp's adventure comes a Disney
animated film that's nothing like
they're lazy direct-to-video sequels of
the past because this one came out in
theaters the paws frozen this happens
annually every time we bring up an
animated sequel every time we bring up
an animated sequel a direct video one
the animated sequel defenders come out
of the woodwork yeah granted I haven't
seen all of them I haven't seen the one
people mentioned that they like is that
there's a Lion King one that they like
simple surprise it was pride yeah but
I've seen return of Jafar yeah
I've seen enough of them to just make a
blanket statement no they're actually
bad you were just a baby the point is
none of them I would argue the ones that
I've seen even if you like them none of
them are up to the standards of the
originals because if they had been then
they would have been yet probably
released theatrically yeah and that's
the point is like it is a lot of them
are perfectly fine they're just they're
Devi levels they're like a 90s
television level which I think the
Aladdin was initially developed as a
Saturday morning cartoon series and
they're like you know what if we put
this in a big soft clamshell VHS case
kids to spend $24.99 on it and they did
and they dan congratulations yes it's
fine we all like bad things and then
keep bring up the the the title sequence
the the frozen two titles there's a joke
that I didn't even think to I didn't
bother recording but it was ours or the
those are coming up the ones that we
know we didn't know we didn't even I
didn't even put them a script because I
forgot but when I saw that I went Aurora
Borealis
right here at this time of year in my
title sequence but I couldn't pull it
off so there you go there's your steamed
hams joke for the weekend cool all right
let's keep going
six years after afros had melted your
heart you grew up and moved on to better
things but when there's money to be made
some companies just can't let it go
in this scattershot follow-up wrapped
around an albums worth of b-sides that's
vague and world-building enough to set
the stage for frozen's three through
seven and a half scams we had a lot of
fun coming up with these we did always a
good time yeah the return of the villain
that you thought was dead we thought was
a pretty good trope guaranteed the
search for more money a good Spaceballs
joke it's always yes yep oops just Olaf
that's a serial reference right yeah
that's just crunchberries reference
we're a Cap'n Crunch hit the wrong lever
on the machine that makes Captain Crunch
and they still haven't fixed it because
it's still in supermarkets yeah my
favorite is for seven in the gritty
reboot yeah I told that he had an
initial draft Kevin that was it that was
more colorful no you gotta wash that out
that's the gritty reboot that's the
that's like the jigsaw of the series
yeah if you put that frozen three out
cold poster out and told me that that
was gonna be a directed I would buy that
I'd say yeah thing is we got this we got
frozen fever except instead of putting
it on VHS it was a they stuck it in
front of Coco I think it was well no
there was frozen fever which was on like
a Pixar reel or some kind of and then
there was Olaf's big adventure Oh which
was supposed to be like a TV special was
like an 18 minute short and they put it
in front of Coco because they thought
that they'd have trouble getting people
to go see Coco but it turns out Coco was
really good and the people were really
pissed off that they had to sit through
an 18 minute long short movie yeah it
was a whole mess yeah yeah do you think
well I guess they didn't overestimate
how much people like frozen because this
made more money than frozen mostly
because like worldwide well worldwide I
don't think it and well I don't know I
have to look domestically yeah haven't I
haven't compared the two but we're gonna
get frozen three at least do you think
I mean it made a billion dollars they
both did so it's gonna be real hard for
Disney to not do that yeah because
they've made a lot of Halloween comes -
should we make a movie or not make that
movie Disney lately has always fall on
the side of we're going to make that
just make the movie so yeah new chairman
- that's right yes in the old news by
tomorrow but adjust it but he's not
doing the creative stuff not yet ya know
like you're still doing the creative
stuff the guy overs from the Parks
Department he's a new CEO yeah and so I
girl be overseeing the princess
Cinematic Universe that we're all
creeping towards because you see you
well we'll talk about that okay we'll do
that next week all your favorite
characters are back to who they were at
the beginning of frozen one else's still
moping on balconies honest still caught
between her sister and a mr. Christophe
has so little to do they give him the
part of a 1930s comedy act I said you'd
have to be crazy to want to marry a man
you just met wait what crazy you didn't
say I was crazy you think I'm crazy
puzzle it it's just especially galling
cuz like now I get it you don't have
much for Kristoff to do and you got a
hold on sambala you got a service but
like to make honor this [ __ ] it's it's
it's my at least one of my least
favorite contrivances is the contrivance
of it'll come bad communication or of
like wordplay that could be clear now
clearly cleared up yeah yeah like listen
dummy marry me and then I'm trying to
propose to you
belaboured all the way to the the
special north all trip proposal ceremony
which is like you stand on a reindeer
and do it yeah do they all do this or
you grab reindeer jumping around and
weird when you wait for someone like in
the mist for them to show their are
they've been cut off for decades
by a mist we've got to do something yeah
basically like Galapagos finches they
like specialized to a degree where they
can't mate with us anymore yes they
literally can because the movie ends not
with everyone living together peacefully
but with a policy of just like great
we'll be up here and you'll be down
there
so weird it's very odd we'll find I
think there's another part where we want
to talk about this more so let's keep
going it was crazy you think I'm crazy
no Oh doing his best I'll hold it all
together until he joins the Disney Hall
of dust this is a weird recurring thing
the character grows they make up or in
costume upgrades with the sparkly
personal growth dress this is fearless
Queen Elsa with a cosmic dream cape
idiot and wears new permafrost Olaf are
you ready to set up on a quest to
discover the dark secret of arendelle
not so fast first listen to this bedtime
story and then a lullaby then get a
crime song stuck in your head
pause so we made a Grimes reference and
then Dan said wait who's Grimes
yeah just curious like I guess she's
borderline I thought she had crossed
over into mainstream cultural
consciousness I'm sure to some folks but
yeah I'm this shade of your grandparents
really III keep I keep I keep up on like
it's a degree of things yes many many
things that I have to be like what
that's fair everyday ones like oh you
didn't hear about this on Twitter I'm
like I know I'm sorry
I did not know that's fair keep Dampier
you don't need to know bad crimes but
but you should be our barometer because
if you haven't heard of it you know it's
probably not worth putting in a nostril
but then I don't know sometimes there's
some things you don't know that surprise
oh no we put in so many things I don't
understand that words so I don't use me
as a metric alright
I'm the metric for like if you're like
parents or perhaps if you have older
siblings might get it or not
no don't judge the mainstream by me and
I've just I've begun the process of
separating from pop culture entirely
entirely as it happens as you get older
I just think it's a little accelerated
in my case that's fine because as we all
know music
peaked in the late 90s early 2000s and
there's no need to go beyond that no
nothing good has been made since then
since Papa Roach access for adult pre
and post Roach yeah Adele is one of the
few post Roach artists worth listening
to
I stopped listening at the bloody bet
black backpack you've six silver chair
maybe get your little black backpack
turn around it's on your back bloody
black backpack back I don't know it's a
time of tongue twisters yeah okay let's
keep going what's your favorite Eve
six-song sound off in the comments below
crime song stuck in your head
[Music]
then everyone just kind of meets up for
a hey did a song about how every mission
in life okay I guess we have time for a
full game of charades then just one more
lullaby there's a joke in the movie that
else is terrible at charades yes but she
obviously has the spatial ability to
make shapes
she can make she made a castle she's a
fantastic visual imagination right she
could like like like like poof her hands
and like make very very evocative three
dimensional rendering so I was the
biggest plot hole for me you would think
that she would actually be okay it's
charades you wouldn't think that
wouldn't you yeah and like you know
honest seems to like have a good
understanding with her that they could
you know siblings like mm-hmm
my brother and I one time it's a true
story we're playing charades family
charades and an extended group I can
call witnesses on this mm-hmm
he said he gets up there and goes right
he says four words and I go Memoirs of a
Geisha I don't know where it came from
but like you have you know you live with
someone you grow up with them and you
just know what they're thinking and I
knew he was thinking about Memoirs of a
Geisha
yeah and I know you know charades and
ice powers don't this but the idea that
you can't get across something that just
seems like you would think that would be
an actual abilities you think you think
I bet she's great at pictionary I'll bet
she is so give that one a ass in oh wait
wrong show all right ping where's the
bell now we'll set up in the quest you
frozen won managed to fit all the plot
and character set up into one song with
time left over to build a snowman
he turned the diamond right right
Moe can still go explore the enchanted
forest known as the enchanted forest a
hidden world full of cutting-edge
particle effects and doh rejects from
Avatar The Last Airbender
it's a puzzle it's always the go-to - to
be like they're a native tribe who has
master of the elements isn't it that and
I don't think it made it in there but
the idea of the chief of the guard being
like the main black character in the
movie yeah because he had not the main
but oftentimes if there will be like the
person who's like the chief like there
was a well there's captain Typho from
Star Wars and then even when you go to
like Hunger Games
muhuali was like the the chief of the
protective like that's also well they
don't make you know enough rom-coms have
the black best friend every more anymore
right have the black captain of the
guard that's the rom-com but it's the
action movie of the black best from the
rom-com is the captain of the guard now
look where we should obviously tread
lightly is two white men talk about race
in this movie yes that said Elsa and
Anna are part North Aldrin apparently
who in this film all everyone in North
all drew is like you know like a
representing some type of indigenous
people like maybe into it or some
northern indigenous tribe except their
moms like lily-white yeah what's going
on there well I'll tell you what they
made a movie before this
oh when before they had ever decided and
they couldn't really change the design
of her character right so to say so shut
up about that also
and similar ancestry question there dad
yeah massive honker on his face he's
like half notes he's like like Beeker
wait the big nose er on the muppet
because I know the big orange nose
somebody her dad was like was like
Gerard Depardieu and and both of them
dodged that bullet so that must be a
recessive gene the large nose yeah and
that family anyways food for thought
yeah don't think too hard about frozen
dunno let's keep go Airbender there they
learn the dark truth about Erin Jo long
ago they betrayed the indigenous people
to the north and by long ago
I mean grandpa did it yeah pause again
sorry we compared this movie to thor
ragnarok a lot of similarities the the
mythical kingdom actually was built on
you know colonial exploitation of
people's et cetera and for Ragnarok you
know they're immortal demigods make
sense that things could be lost to time
it had millions of years it was so long
ago they've they've painted new frescoes
on the ceiling and stuff like that but
when your grandparents did it I imagine
there's people over 65 still oh yeah
remember that I mean you're the princess
I guess the I guess the history is
written by the winners so I guess I
guess the the prevailing tale that had
made it was that there was some sort of
a conflict but nobody really knew what
happened yeah but you know even the
people who participated in it but I
guess they all got trapped in in oh yeah
I got trapped in the mist except for the
prince who was rescued by the very non
null tree and looking mother yeah I I
still think that again like it's it's
it's a hat we talking about the fact
that they really don't want to delve
into the deep but not every movie has to
but again I love that the from the
takeaway from this is just like we've
exposed the horrors of your past my
grandfather slaughtered you're the
leader of your tribe and
you know in print cause the imprisonment
of your people in this mist for decades
and so now that this isn't exposed I
will stay here as your ruler but what
yeah
forget the that's great if the mist
people and an equal grandpa that's one
thing but you had to have cooperation to
build that dam project project damn them
all
well the dam was a trick yeah they
thought it was good who thought it well
yeah but it was good and and the grandad
was all you know twisting his mustache
and and and considered was gonna make
them dependent on arendelle so but but
yes no the the assumption was that the
dam was good yeah and then I think that
the the guy the the north old during guy
got wise to it and and there you have it
I did appreciate it I did appreciate how
quickly Anna is completely radicalized
into an eco-terrorist they're done for
that's look you know she's she's like
instantly
yeah eco-terrorist monkey wrench gang
blowing them blown up monuments all
right well says I think that that thing
that that naired and again when you're
not planning that narrative had emerged
after the first frozen when they're like
why does one of them have to be the
Queen and one of the white kids they
both be the Queen and so they I think
they had to get into a place by the end
of this movie worth like well they both
have to be Queen mm-hmm so how do we do
that yeah you know all right so that's
the the perils of success yeah public
opinion now weighing in on you tough
alright difficult let's keep going
I mean grandpa did it but if you think
this is setting up some hard choices or
sacrifice or even commentary on
historical injustice it is it
everything's just fine who else was in
on the plot did the people to the north
want revenge
shut up else's got a water horse now so
strap in for a brand new frozen that
could get sued by thor ragnarok if
Disney didn't already own every day we
do this together okay there's no one
bent auto history Odin and I drowned
entire civilizations in blood and tears
but that goes against everything
arendelle stands for I'm made of rocks
as you can see if he couldn't still fool
yourself there are a lot fewer honest
trailer monsters spent reminiscing about
it when you pretend to be Christ up and
you're like I climb to the North
Mountain survived a frozen heart and
safety from my ex-boyfriend sisters one
born with magical powers one born
powerless what did happen to your
parents ship went down in the southern
sea six years ago
[Music]
do you want to build a snowman and if
you're expecting song parodies at this
point inspiration didn't really strike
twice for this movie and it didn't for
us either so just go scream into the
unknown as loud as you can until you
pass out you get the gist yeah it's
perfect yeah
people preview a fan question is why we
didn't do any songs I couldn't really
name any of the songs
aside from into the unknown know they
kind of just yeah and also a little
preview we're working on two very very
musical honest trailers on their way
yeah and we kind of had to pick and
choose where we want to put our time and
energy into and I think the ones coming
up will be more worth have been doing
covers of the of the b-side a frozen two
song hopefully once you see the two
trailers one of them a little more
traditional one of them even more
musical I think then we're used to doing
the in the style of other musical
trailers I've done I think you will
agree hopefully with us that that it was
worth the sacrifice of not doing
parodies for this movie to get those
done because you know there's no we can
only make so much music right they can
only have so much music yes was it
difficult to write parodies you know
there's no songs that no one knows in
the first place right so it's like
what's the joke on cuz the first one
like every song just about was like at
least like four or five songs that were
earworms yes III would wait you to say
that no song in this film even into the
unknown approaches the level of even a
low I'm not even gonna go let it go even
a love is an open door yeah from the
first movie yeah so not even a
fixer-upper maybe we even make no that's
like
exactly but yeah yeah no good for you no
adele dazeem fitra she was trying her
heart her heart out she's trying to just
through sheer force of will put this
song in your head just by she got to
perform on the Oscars again it was an
Oscar nominated song all we mrs. ty Elsa
we got to meet all of the all the Elsa's
from around the world yeah it's a global
else is screaming at you from every
continent yes so we have we have them to
thank for that
anyways that's just a preview we were
more music to come if you don't stop
doing music we just placed our musical
interest elsewhere so let's keep going
yeah pretty frosty the sidekick the last
black man in Arundale they moved like
big strong hands neverending story
I believe this Norwegian Rhapsody the
best friend from a rom-com that plays
basketball with the male lead the blink
and you'll miss it yeah character that
Disney will Pat itself in the back about
third boss currently going through a new
cycle of that with onward yeah yeah an
exclusively gay moment yeah this at
least was not highlighted it seems by
the studio itself it's been pointed out
but it's okay still it's like great you
have a character line right about the
girlfriend they had back home yeah I
mean it's it's tricky cuz like on one on
one hand it's like cool to normalize it
just like some characters are gay and
it's not a big deal and not a big focus
of their character but then and and they
didn't make a big stink about not stink
they didn't like pat themselves on the
back this time but sometimes they're
like oh yeah we're gonna put a tiny
little gay nod in this movie yes we're
going to trumpet it out that we've put a
gay character and then we're gonna cut
it when it plays in
game yeah they did it with the rise of
Skywalker they do the Beast
they're already doing it with eternals
yeah I am all for it
I'm all for inclusion but like just do
it yeah just do it's not a story you
don't have to be like the per we have a
game extra bernal's
great okay you know you know you know
what actual inclusion is just do it and
don't say anything about them and then
and normal the real telling see because
it is the telling thing is that they
leave those shots they make them just
little shots that they can remove them
like when they play around the world the
real risk would be putting it in such a
central position that you would have to
go to a foreign market and say you
either have to accept this or not we're
not or we're gonna sacrifice your money
yeah but as I mentioned before when it
comes to to having taking money or not
taking money right now Disney will say I
will please take please yeah so yeah so
it goes now I love I love the fact that
they're that they are weaving a fabric
of humanity but like don't just don't
take the lap yeah don't take the victory
let's do it yeah there you go there you
go anyways whatever two straight guys
take God roll tape
the Disney will pet it's up on the back
about
[Music]
I don't know if we set that up well
enough because they make a whole thing
about earth air fire water and Elsa
combined yeah Supreme Being and sad
Alice multipass do they own the Fifth
Element no shocks it was a fox film cuz
then we could really be cooking this
[Music]
get Chris Tucker back in there yes this
element so those guys France distributed
by gum on when a Vista
okay that's Disney okay so I think I
think I think it's a Disney I think it
might be a Disney I think Leeloo Dallas
is a Disney Princess
yeah that's great that's I mean I mean
you you you now have you've got you've
got it you got a Fifth Element you got
Elsa is the fifth element you don't even
have to it writes itself
yeah that's like a lot of these movies
seem to because they're all remakes of
movies that were written 30 years yeah
they literally have written themselves
yes yeah through the hard work of other
people who don't get paid no but they
put those scripts into one of those
autocomplete a eyes and then just take
it from there well yeah that's true
I would love to see the return of
manuals org in any form Disney or
otherwise he looks like an enemy yeah
like just just let's let's cut out the
middleman here and just make him uh make
him a character making my animated
character bring back Gary Oldman God
knows he's worked long enough back up
the Brinks truck yes get him in yeah
yeah make a first Willis Karen ed yes he
was well that's impossible
alright what else we got still going
yeah rise of ice Walker nice leaves
hoping well almost only three years old
and he's already doing observational
comedy every errand alien ship has a
compartment waterproof that's very
clever although it does make me wonder
why they don't just make the whole
ship's water per day
now as memory serves that is an actual
Seinfeld bit on the plane saying recover
the black box from the airplane I'm
almost positive that was that was
definitely a bit but I'm almost sure it
was a Seinfeld I think that should make
the whole airplane out of the ball yeah
it's classic Seinfeld observation it
really is yeah oh yeah what a world
let's check them out I don't feel so
good
mother truth I do the album gotta
heimdal captain Typho this is him static
embarrass myself my name is kook I'm
kind of like the leader up here
lazy stoners Pascal from tangled
reindeer games Kris Kristofferson
follows sister tribe a horse girl and
set Dallas monkey pasta
arendale the last ice bender that's
definitely not how you spell Aaron
Gosselin is that one too frozen to
furious
you know I'm no waterbender but wouldn't
the water just go back and flood the
forest why is Olaf obsessed with getting
older I mean he's the only character in
the franchise who would never grow old
yeah weird choice I actually was curious
about that she puts up the big ice wall
and they're experts on everything that
watch this because the second we get
something wrong we hear about it so I'm
gonna I'm gonna weaponize that expertise
and I'm gonna ask a question they break
a dam but then all the water comes
rushing out its gonna drown Aaron do ya
arendelle right
whatever whatever so then Elsa puts up a
big ice wall and the water all gets
pushed back backwards yes
would it not just return from whence it
came and flood the forest that they had
just come to peace service I mean I feel
like you know when you're in the bathtub
and you're like kind of sloshing back
and forth like this we'll go back hit
some kind of barrier and then like come
back you come back I know that some of
it say like well she turned some of it
into ice and yes she does I can see the
ice crystals there I smell stupid but if
you look there's a large volume of water
that is getting pushed oh yeah backwards
see times so where I would like some
help from the physicists etc maybe it's
all turning to ice I'm just curious
I just from a physics perspective and a
water logic perspective where would all
that water go yeah I mean they're like a
prime global warning warming def Canada
rise of like a gun yep yeah basically
Florida I actually thought that what was
gonna happen was that they were in a
sacrifice arendelle yes and then they
would all go live in the Enchanted
Forest in peace no no everybody cool
yeah there you go
both have Queens we're both we both live
together but not together no harm no
foul no harm no foul well there you go
those are deleted scenes but what did
y'all have to say um come huh Heron
rights did you like any of the songs
actually really like the 80s power
ballad reminds me of the glory of love I
liked it I liked the execution of it I
said
really funny inside the movie but it did
just drive home for me how Christoph's
plotline was a joke and not to be taken
seriously yeah just fine it just wasn't
funny enough to earn that or yeah the
song itself wasn't that hilarious it was
like oh they're doing a little pastiche
of power ballads like yeah it's cute
yeah it was good in the movie but like
take the movie out of it it didn't it
wasn't an earworm like many of the other
ones were for me yeah and honestly like
Olaf song about getting older
understanding things in your older again
cute you know it's like a Disney good
comedy song but none of the other ones
like I can't even remember the other
ones of aside from into the unknown and
those two what else did they sing well
there did the trolls sing anything this
time
no they just kind of rolled in because
they have to be in the movie and they're
like we'll stay here watch the people of
arendelle while we all go on this
adventure they're like all right thanks
trolls the hero 1:36 writes I feel like
I'm the only one in a very small
minority that liked this film more than
frozen one anyone else not at this table
but that's fine well no I said that I
think that it's like script wise I think
it's better I just don't think the music
was anywhere close to his good which
affects the overall sure I think if he
had this story with music that was on
par with the first one for me then I
would have liked it better good but for
now I'm there they're kind of on equal
footing
yep for me maybe I am maybe I might like
this one just a little better but it's
very close cool uh sir Stoneheart writes
maybe it's just me but doesn't the
honest trailers about sequels seem
rather mean in particular sequels with
this one it chapter 2 Halloween you're
not wrong
I think that it's like you know if
there's a mission statement two honest
trailers it's to be honest about the the
rationale behind films and just to help
you not be duped it's to help you not to
notice the BS that gets pushed on us and
I think that when you're making a sequel
it's rarely because there's a good story
to tell it's money first and then
they find the story to justify it yeah
and we just that kind of you know grinds
my gears yeah
most sequels I would say to some extent
or another are an attempt to recapture
the excitement or innovation or
originality of the previous film now it
chapter two I think it's different it's
chapter two I just think we all thought
was like way too long kind of formless
structureless and we made the mistakes
of the of the miniseries slash book
whereas one really took what was great
about the books and discarded everything
else they had an opportunity to do the
same thing in the second chapter now
more of their own story but they went
right back to be sort of flawed source
material totally all over the place just
is all about side quests that don't
really connect but yeah I think it is
probably if you go back that sequels do
kind of get a hard a hard hard test from
us because I think by and large a lot of
them it's hard to reinvent the wheel and
when you're at a comedy show about
movies you're looking for the easy you
know or the the soft spots the
vulnerable spots and that is the a lot
of sequels have the same vulnerable spot
which is hey we're just like the
original and we're gonna remind you
about it but it's not quite as good yeah
we're gonna add just enough but
essentially this is a play on your
nostalgia it's not you know whatever
strange all kimete gets an original
story made where you're like I have this
great idea I have something I need to
share with the world that's not where
sequels come from right and Halloween
for me was very much about like the fact
that it's sold itself is not another
sequel like it's nowhere it's the epic
conclusion to the and then it's like no
you're just another ticket again you're
just setting up more sequels it's a
different kind of sequel I'll grant you
that but like it's ya know you're just
another Halloween see yeah I don't
remember us being particularly mean in
Halloween but after we watch it I was I
was pretty mean I don't know about the
trailers but I was very mean me you
didn't like it yeah I was not a fan I
didn't hate it but I was not a big thing
that was fun anyways that's it for this
shrinking down
episode of honest trailer commentaries
but we'll be back next week maybe with a
fuller cast just me to talk about
something that oh gosh maybe you want to
throw some of your money at us for it
for doing it a in appreciation yeah so
there you go that's your clue and we'll
see right here next week cause trailer
commentaries my back
[Music]
you